[Music]
you mentioned me once that you do you
love the Korean spas that are here in
Los Angeles you said that I do yeah and
and i was curious is that something
you're you're still are you still going
to have intense the Korean spa in a
while I've been to the Russian spa I
mean where do the two different
continents yeah tell me what are these
are there's Korean spa is down in will
sure there's a good few of them down on
Wilshire they're really good man the 24
hours you go in and what time do you go
the time I mean I'm not great at
sleeping I'm great at staying asleep but
I'm not great at falling asleep so I'd
usually the times I've been around 2:00
or 3:00 in the morning
so you go to a spa right down yeah yeah
just dries out on me I'll go and get a
monkey pair of slippers in a towel and
get out of here okay and when you say we
go who's going with you yet you go with
friends or is it I have been with
friends but usually on my own yeah yeah
what you want to go I wouldn't you know
what I've been fascinated I've been
hearing about these spas and I'm like
yeah I will go I think who and I should
go somewhere I'll pick you up some night
men yeah I would go at like 3:00 in the
morning weird Andy do you want to come
with us
not at 3:00 in the morning - all right -
[Applause]